[Music]
what i was telling her
a minute ago i think it's worth you and
i unpacking for a minute because we've
talked about it on air and off both
um when you started digging into the
student loan crisis
and our team started really doing the
research into it
and started breaking it down um
you know we see people that pay too much
yes pick their own school they pick the
wrong school
they pick a degree that has no profit
that has no
uh career possibilities equal to what
they've paid meaning there's no roi
no return on investment on this level of
education
uh and so you know if you can become
a high school math teacher uh for
uh you know twelve thousand dollars a
year at your local state school tuition
which is what the state schools
average right now or you can spend fifty
thousand dollars a year
for exactly the same job uh and if you
were gonna go into that we'd say it's
two hundred thousand
versus uh forty thousand yes
yes uh we're not gonna tell you go into
that but when you just compare those two
things right there
for the for for the exact same career
field right
uh it's asinine it definitely is what
people have been led to do
chosen to do yeah dave and another thing
that we've i've learned is people
are i'm gonna say this respectfully
they're lazy
they don't want to step back and do the
research and see what are the programs
and the opportunities out there
you're talking about 40 000 let's go
even a little bit deeper dave
if you go to like one of the schools
let's say unc wilmington unc
pembroke you can actually if you get
accepted into the school
you you will only pay five hundred
dollars up in one of their programs
a semester that's a thousand dollars a
year four thousand dollars
for a bachelor's degree to become a
school teacher yeah but people do not
want to step
back and do the research know what they
want to do if they're in north carolina
they want to go to chapel hill they want
to go to duke they want to go to these
big names which is nothing wrong with it
but they think
if i go to duke i'd be a better school
teacher than going to unc pembroke
no no no not no you know
you're getting the same education going
to the same school getting paid the same
money
but you paid 10 times more than actually
stepping
back and doing the research and picking
the right school
that's going to elevate you give you the
education which is important
but what is your long-term gain yeah so
here's the warning for you guys out
there
um if you whether you're the student
that's watching us maybe on youtube and
you're thinking of going into college
in the future you're 17 18 16 19
whatever in that age group or whether
you're the parent
the thing that anthony and i have seen
where the
largest mistakes happen
i mentioned to her earlier it was her
mom
didn't know anything about higher
education facts yeah
yeah because she hadn't gone to college
and there's no shame in that
but it's like buying a car and you've
never owned one yeah
and you go well you know you need to get
a bentley
you know you ought to get a mercedes
because i heard they're really good
but i've never owned a car i've never
even driven a car
that's a good that's a you know example
and so uh but you know but i heard
they're really good yeah
i heard those mercedes are really good
cars yeah well i ain't gain money
but i'm gonna go sign up for chevrolet
because my mom i mean i'm gonna go sign
up for a
bentley or a mercedes instead of a
chevrolet because my mom or dad has
never been there
so mom and dad if you've if you didn't
go to school
there is zero shame in that as a matter
of fact it might just be awesome that
you didn't go to school i'm
you're not in debt life is good right
but if your kid is getting ready to go
to school
get some people in your corner
that have that have a have a four-year
degree
that uh have made some of the mistakes
maybe
uh that aren't thinking like society is
thinking like our broken culture is
thinking
because otherwise you could really screw
up your kid
yeah by allowing by two things one is
allowing them to pay too much and two is
allowing them to study
um left-wing feminism or something and
then all of a sudden you've got no
ability to get a job because there's no
such thing as a job for that yeah
and you can you can study it if you want
to study it but
uh whatever the thing is left-handed
puppetry
bb stacking i don't know what everything
is we want to make fun of
that is a useless freaking degree and
then you pay
200 000 bucks in debt to get a useless
freaking degree
this most often happens in first
generation where the college
yes where their parents did not go to
school when you and i first started
looking at this
we we had the hypothesis that uh that it
was more racial
because you were seeing a lot of people
in the black community yes that were
having this exact problem
exactly and you kept going this is my my
people yeah and this is a problem and i
kept going is it is it really a racial
thing
and because and then we dove into the
numbers and we went yeah
but black people whose parents went to
school went to college
aren't making that mistake it turns out
it's not a it's not a racial thing at
all
it's it's it's a it's mostly the data
tells us as we've studied this and
researched it
that regardless of your skin color yep
uh it is
your propensity to do something really
really damaging to yourself
because your parents didn't know how to
guide you through it absolutely
and give you bad advice here's the thing
what i'm learning about the second
generation dave
is the first generation parent goes to
school and then the parent says all
right i want you to go to my school
because if you go to my school you'll
get better network you'll get a better
network to go get your dream job so then
you go to your parents school
to and rack up all this debt just so i
can meet dave ramsey
and hopefully dave ramsey can connect me
to another
place to get a job which i think that is
completely false as well now networking
is important yeah but you if you
you don't need to go you don't need to
spend uh 50 000 bucks to get a network
no
that's that's absolute that's ridiculous
so the thing the thing is this
so i'm second generation my my mom and
dad did not go to college
okay so i mean i'm first generation my
kids are second generation right
they went to my school yeah but i did
not send them there for the network
right
i didn't even send them there because i
was romantically involved with the
school like i love the university of
tennessee
and you didn't make them go there yeah i
did
[Laughter]
um i didn't know that absolutely that's
good to know
um i told them they had to go to an
in-state school yeah so
that's that's like the choice i mean it
was
mtsu middle tennessee state university
east tennessee state university or the
university of tennessee and neither
pretty well at
the university of tennessee knoxville
university tennessee chattanooga right
memphis state right i mean these are
your schools you're going to go to
in-state tuition because i'm not going
to pay out-of-state tuition
and if you and i do not
find any piece of data that says where
you went to school is correlated with
your success
okay i can't find that anywhere
absolutely education is important
where you got it turns out there's not a
single piece of research right that says
you're more successful if you went to
harvard right
you can't find it okay it's it's
mythology
and seth godin calls it in a borrowed
future
he's he doesn't call them um prestigious
schools he calls them famous
schools yeah that's it they've become
famous
any schools they're not necessarily
better they're just
famous right oh my kid went to such a
citizen
and and and you paid how much to be able
to make that's one stupid sentence
yeah man oh my god it's unbelievable we
gotta tell dave offline though we made
your kids go to a school
i made them go to an in-state school and
i paid i was paying for it so i get the
right to decide where you're going
that's right i give you i have this
weird thing i think i'm in charge